it's just as a humble to be the
recipient of such a say the
distinguished a word with so much
meaning behind it
Kim Phuc is famous for being the subject
of a photograph a photograph of such
power that it galvanized public opinion
around the world about the war in
Vietnam and helped change the course of
history
I avoid a void totally to look my
picture alone my mouth my eyes my body
it's the worst moment of human being as
a little girl I felt so embarrassed why
I was naked and my brother's mic housing
was closed on
[Music]
I just dude fry there
and I turned my head and I saw four
bombs landing like that fire was
everywhere
and the fire actually burned my clothes
off I was nine you know and I remember I
thought oh my goodness
I got burned so I would be ugly and so
people would see me different way of
course that moment that picture that day
changed my life forever now I know I
have a picture I am NOT in a feeling
embarrassed like before but it's not
much to me until the moment when I have
a child I look at my boy never one the
children suffer like that little go with
me and so from that point is it it
really touched me and that picture
became so powerful gift for me if
everyone can learn to live with love
with hope and forgiveness absolutely we
don't need war at all if that little
girl in that picture can do it so
everyone can do it too
you